one of the leaders here of the
Sinquefield cop Levon Aronian is with
Maurice Ashley and today they don't
match what
yeah the Armenian superstar didn't get
the memo so I got to make sure I write
that note to you stick it on to your
door what's happening next day well of
course always dapper drawing today
against Magnus we're seeing the e4
insistence even against the best in the
world you said I could play any chess
move yeah I think I mean it's risky but
as they say in Russia the one who
doesn't risk doesn't drink champagne so
I like that in order to fight you need
to take some risky decisions I think you
had a position that wasn't extremely
complicated and sort of was always level
in in the assessment but there was a
moment in the game when you could have
created an imbalance and allowed two
rooks to appear on the board with a
little bit of chances for white what are
your thoughts if you may help us through
the analysis we have it on the screen
right now after this move taking on 87
and allowing this position following up
with Queen d2 and looking to get the
Queen and the knight in and trying to
make something I think Buki 8 is a
strong move here this I didn't like so
much
rook to e8 so rook e8 night at five and
then Luke a8 right in Quetta for Magnus
said that he thought that that he would
go for this maneuver but he we didn't
get a chance to expand in detail but he
said that maybe he'd give up the b-pawn
and still be okay would you agree with
that assessment the general feel is that
blacks should be okay generally in such
operations but maybe this is a this is
the case that maybe whitey slightly
better here
yeah it it seemed to me that blacks
should have enough time to consolidate
the claim control so that's why I didn't
go for it but now it looks good when you
guys are are moving the pieces of course
we get to move the pieces so maybe he
should play rookie six here and then
Queen f4 okay 827 yeah probably
something like b5 yeah this should shoot
somehow be sufficient
even with a five if I was one idea but
between b75 g6 if I think doesn't lead
anywhere I probably should get the phone
but then once again the rook a e8 and
you take takes takes and then he'll
probably play g6 cutting that night
night at five this looks really risky
for white 94
hmm okay yeah but generally I don't
think this is anything serious for what
because once black consolidates should
be fine like someone that's what I feel
all right
stuff we will have to look at more
deeply you are still tired at the top
your feelings about the situation
overall after three rounds I think my
play is fine so I just need to continue
fighting and trying to improve my score
so that's the goal and I enjoy playing
some new openings for me so so far it
looks like a good tournament make it fun
enough for your friend Maxine brush to
the ground for not winning any games
over you ever talk in the middle of a
tournament like trash talk to each other
in the middle vitória no because I mean
only when the guys lose then then you
can crash so and they don't it's you
know you're trying to trash talk them
into losing more all right well we will
let you go and Thursday a nice
relaxation what are you planning to do
now you have so much time I'll probably
go through the gym do some weights I
mean cause it's raining I won't go for a
run so yeah that's my plan
got it all right well I wish I could see
you there but we still got work to do so
enjoy the rest of the evening thank you